nuevamente la empresa de gas ruso
gazprom disminuye la cantidad de gas que
exporta a la multinacional energética
francesa y la empresa ya está
dependiendo apenas en un 4% del gas ruso
según moscú esto se debe a un problema
interpretación en los contratos sin
embargo la ministra de transición
energética francesa volvió a acusar a
rusia de utilizar el gas como un arma de
guerra desde allí se han encargado de
tranquilizar a la población dicen que
tienen acumulada energía suficiente para
hacer frente a los meses que vienen e
incluso para prescindir del gas o rusos
y moscú decidiera cortarlo
definitivamente la noticia preocupa pues
llega en todo un momento en que en
francia el gobierno está en una campaña
para economizar energía destinada a la
población pero también y sobre todo a
los empresarios el día viernes el
presidente manuel macrón ha convocado un
consejo de defensa energético es algo
excepcional será la primera vez pues
este consejo en realidad está dedicado
como lo dice su nombre a temas de
defensa en la época del cobach se amplió
a los temas sanitarios para hacer frente
a esa guerra contra la pandemia
claro el presidente manuel macro y este
será el primero dedicado a la energía se
hablará de donde encontrar nuevas
fuentes de energía de gas concretamente
la semana pasada el presidente macro no
estuvo en argelia y esa es una de las
posibilidades pero también es una medida
de comunicación para mostrar la urgencia
de la crisis energética por parte del
gobierno y también para demostrar que el
gobierno está trabajando en ello de
hecho ayer la primera ministra lisa de
bonn se reunía con los empresarios y les
recordaba que iban a ser ellos los
primeros afectados por eventuales
racionamientos o cortes de energía si no
comienzan a mostrar sobriedad en sus
gastos energéticos